juan logra el 25 por ciento de los tiros
de tres puntos que realiza como
calentamiento juan hace tiros de tres
puntos hasta que logra acertar uno esta
parte de que hasta que logra acertar uno
nos indica que se trata de una variable
geométrica sea m el número de tiros que
hace juan hasta lograr su primer tiro de
tres puntos esta variable aleatoria es
el número de tiros que hace juan hasta
lograr su primer tiro de tres puntos
supón que los resultados de cada tiro
son independientes la probabilidad de
que logre un tiro exitoso no depende de
si fueron o no exitosos los tiros
anteriores encuentran la probabilidad de
que el primer tiro exitoso de juan
ocurre en la tercera ejecución y los
invito a qué pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar la respuesta resolvamos
estos juntos
m es el número de tiros que hace juan
hasta lograr su primer tiro de tres
puntos así que realmente nos están
preguntando cuál es la probabilidad de
que m sea igual a 3 que su primer tiro
exitoso ocurre a la tercera ejecución lo
escribimos
como resolvemos esto para que esto
ocurra juan debió fallar sus primeros
dos tiros y después lograr que su tercer
tiro fuera exitoso cuál es la
probabilidad de que falle su primer tiro
si nos dicen que tiene un cuarto de
probabilidad de lograr un tiro exitoso
entonces tiene una probabilidad de tres
cuartos de fallar el tiro tenemos
entonces tres cuartos para que falle el
primer tiro también tenemos otros tres
cuartos que es la probabilidad de que
falle el segundo tiro finalmente tenemos
la probabilidad de que su tercer tiro
sea exitoso
esta es la probabilidad falla falla y
acierta a que es igual esto 9 entre 64
este es el resultado si queremos verlo
en decimales sacamos la calculadora para
hacer la operación más rápido 9 entre 64
es aproximadamente igual a 0.14 otra
forma de pensar en esto es que hay
aproximadamente un 14 por ciento de
probabilidad de que el primer tiro
exitoso de juan sea el tercero y con
esto terminamos